[Music]
we have 3.7 million farmers and more
than 10 million fish ones all across
Indonesia
the first trading Market is a 10 billion
dollar market already in Indonesia the
Feed Market is a 5 billion dollar market
but that's only Indonesia
but if we see on the global issues the
aquaculture is a hundreds of billion
dollar market
my dream was to operate my own fish
farms a thousand of fish bombs that was
my dream I met many farmers that operate
news a hundred pounds 200 pounds even a
thousand pounds and why not soaked to
many farmers I saw similar problems that
the farmers faced
all Farmers know that the cost is the
biggest cost is 70 to 90 of the total
cost and currently done manually by
labor so the quality of the feed that
you produce is really depending on
whether the labor feed your fish
properly and from that discussion
impulsively it's just a spontaneous idea
that I pitched on Farmers hey what if I
can build a machine that you can feed
your fish from your phone and if these
problems is the same with all of the
farmers then we even have much bigger
opportunity
[Music]
my name is gibra nuzaifa I'm CEO and
co-founder of efficiary
what's up I can say that I grew up
pretty poor
both of my parents married quite early
so they didn't settle with economically
but if I remember what it feels like
during my childhood it's all about you
know happiness
so that part gave me an idea that it's
not always about in the world the money
but it's it's about the relationship
that we built
when I started my own fish farming back
then in college there's not really an
external problems that I was trying to
solve it's just about solving my own
problems and try to be independent back
then when I was in college
but it got me to a realization that the
the massive opportunity of the sector is
really big and that started officially
from that point
our approach is really how we can help
small scale and small older Farmers to
increase their productivity and provide
efficiency on their biggest costs which
is feeding so that's why we started on
building this officially feeder so this
is a machine to fit the fish
automatically that is connected to the
cloud and connected the sensor that can
sense the fish appetite so it can
improve the feed efficiency of the feed
conversion ratio as well as on
increasing the growth of the fish so
they can shorten the Harvest Cycles when
they use this kind of technology that is
a radically affordable they only need to
pay 10 per month to use this they will
see that their farming practices improve
because the technology is embedded in
their operations
foreign
is even more interesting because this
technology opening a new doors for us to
capture a lot of data information how
many feet that they're using what's the
feedback frequency per day what brand of
it that they're using and the farmers
can even capture more data information
on how many fish that they will be
harvesting how many fish are there
we try to use the data and build credit
scoring to connect Farmers with the
financial institution so they can
receive the financing from from
Financial intuition directly and we can
also use the data to connect Farmers to
the downstream buyers so in all in all
it's all about increasing the profit on
the farmers by leveraging the data and
Technology
foreign
each of the farmers has received many
benefits at least they productivity and
their income is increased from 40
percent to 200 with so many farmers that
started you know joining a fishery only
on like two ponds but right now they own
20 pounds so their productivity and
their income increased by 10 times only
joining officially in one year
it was really challenging it was not as
easy as I thought it would be because
when we had the product when I went to
the farmers the farmers never really
understood why they need to use this
product because most of the farmers are
very traditional and they've been doing
it for decades they've been feeding the
fish for 20 years and using traditional
model so they don't really know how this
helps and whether this replaced labor
and labor is very cheap in Indonesia but
when I asked them why they want to use
it fishery I thought it would be about
new technology and the solutions the
benefit of the product itself but
apparently not
what Farmers appreciate is about the
community that we need to build about
the sense of belongings on the bigger
mission that we have
so I think that's the biggest lesson
that building this is not just about the
numbers and the metrics but really about
the human side and human relationship
that we need to maintain to build and to
skill
so if I see visually contributing to
that larger ecosystem and and see if we
should play a role on you know feed more
people but also creating a livelihood
then also impacting that rural
communities so that's really what what
drives me what defines my definition of
success it's not about you know the
valuation and my own wealth but it's
really about how a visual can contribute
to General uh you know success of those
communities
we're currently doing a pilot outside
Indonesia we did a pilot in Vietnam we
were currently doing a pilot in India so
we would like to prove the solutions
that coming from Indonesian innovators
building in Indonesia Market can
actually take a big role in the global
aquaculture Market
we're really
excited about the future because we're
pioneering this sector we're technically
creating this category of of fish like
of aquaculture technology that then has
a really big upside on on building the
market and building the sector even
further and aquaculture is still
currently the fastest growing food
sector in the world so for us it's sky
is the limit
[Music]